so our next speaker for the day is
sikhilio and she'll tell us about hyper
connectivity and high dimension
expanders so take it away
so uh I actually while preparing for
this talk I realized in boot camp you
guys already heard about
hyperconductivity and Epson product
space so today I'm just trying to give a
more cohesive view of it and try to fill
some of the gaps maybe you've left to
buy like due to like having different
talks covering this topic so the first
half of the talk I will try to cover
some backgrounds on hyperconductivity
like what like what it really is it
about and the second part I would try to
set up a framework for the proof of
epson product space Global
hyperconductivity and quality
so this talk is based on joint work with
Tom Gore and Noah who's here
um
yeah okay so let's
jump in so maybe it should start slower
with people come in still uh so this is
uh the first size is about the setup so
okay when we consider hyperconductivity
what is the object we really care about
when we're studying right so
to me it feels like really the object we
care about is a probability space which
I don't know by Omega mu where Omega we
should think about just a sample space
and mu is a distribution
and probably like I should also mention
that here another object that we should
always keep in mind when talking about
this kind of properties is the function
space like the space of functions over
this probability space and also we
really required this abundant space so
we need a norm to be defined for all
these functions
I'm not really writing it out explicitly
here but that's what we should think
about
so okay now we have the space we have
the function and now we consider a
linear operator T row that's over L
Infinity mu so L Infinity mu is just the
space of functions real value functions
let's say real value functions over the
space that have bounded Infinity Norm
I will say that this operator over the
space is hypercontractive if it satisfy
the following two requirements
so number one is if F is for every F was
bounded L1 Norm we require that t row
when rho is in the range zero between
zero and one
okay this this t-row we should think
about it just as the noise operator you
guys probably have already seen in the
context of Boolean function analysis
okay and uh when row is larger it's just
a closer to being identity operator and
when it's zero it's closer to being
really a uniform uh
a uniform distribution
so
um
the first requirement is that the L1
Norm of T row should be a t row of f
should be bounded by a L1 Norm of x
okay so this is just saying literally
like tiro should be an averaging
operator should be contracted
and the second requirement is saying
that for there exists a specific row
zero such that if I take my noise to be
a large or I take my averaging operator
row so that row is smaller than row zero
then I have that t row of F's four Norm
is bounded by some constant c times its
two Norm raised to the power of four
right
now
uh yes I'm I'm talking about in the next
slide but yeah usually you want this to
form us
and uh hereby P Norm I really mean like
uh FP to the P really is the uh
uh peace moment of the function f over
this probability space
so
okay also by the way if you have any
questions feel free to interrupt
sorry
absolutely what's the expectation of
absolute value
all right okay yeah that's right okay so
why do we care about L1 in the first I
mean usually it's been effective for all
uh I think if you have L1 contracted you
can derive
derive attractive and in between
contracted yeah so it's important yeah
but right it's literally saying like you
should it should be constructive for all
the
greater
okay so
um
okay now
as uh if I was mentioning uh we actually
usually have this hero being a semi
group
um and the even more specifically T row
is usually this operator which is uh e
to the negative log row times L here L
is the laplacian operator
um okay if we are on the hypercube
Boolean hypercube it's literally
laplacian of the of the graph itself if
we think about the space as a graph but
uh if it's a distribution like a
standard gaussian or something this will
be the distribution of laplation which
will have this definition here the way
you won't really use it too much so just
showing it here and no worries if it's
confusing a little bit
so okay yeah as I mentioned like this T
row is the Weinstein ulenbach semi-group
operator over the gaussian space and uh
it's the noisy operator noise operator
on the Boolean hyper tube
so let's talk a lot in the boot camp I
guess
um
so uh following that I want to say
there's a couple variants or a couple
like different ways of expressing the
hyperconductivity inequality so I just
want to write them out out here so maybe
in some settings you will see like okay
in the previous setting I've shown
um we only have this like uh four no
four Norm is bounded by two Norm
expression but in general once you have
this four Norm is bounded by two Norm
expression you can actually also in the
Black Box way did you use like cut hero
FS Q Norm is bounded by P Norm for every
p and Q uh for every like P greater than
one smaller than Q
this words for yeah you yeah for the
same row
as the one in the fortitude
yeah c yeah right C actually changes C
is no longer the C in the fortitude it's
depending on P and Q
so uh and also I want to say like
sometimes people would drop the D row
when uh and instead having the C
depending on some degree parameter D
especially this is the cases we've seen
in the discrete space like kabulian
Boolean Cube that because this hero
actuates eigenvalue decomposition nicely
corresponds to the degree decomposition
of functions
uh so there's ways to like uh really uh
write T row instead as like some
constant times the different degree
parts of math and therefore being able
to extract the ACB on the right hand
side and dropping T Row in general
in this expression
uh
okay
okay so uh then in the rest of the talk
I will mostly just adapt this notation
where we don't have t row like we just
have the four Norm itself and hiding the
row dependency relay in this C
constant which has also happened to be a
uh
usually you have a degree degree
parameter hidden there but you sometimes
you could have more like more
information about the space also could
influence the value of C
so why do we care about
hyperconductivity and quality I guess
this has also been already talked so I
will just uh summarize some of them so
first is this really in some sense is
abound on the like moment higher moments
of a of a random variable of a function
of a random variable and uh therefore
because one could get this about a
higher moment so one thing one could
immediately get is a
concentration for the random variable f
is probability space
okay so the first one
I'm dropping the process of deduction
but really this is through Markov by by
using a higher uh higher moments than
two and on the right hand side this is
also anti-concentration result so
Sigmund
so this is kind of the more
straightforward
corollary almost like and uh also there
is this so-called degree the inequality
this is
um something one can deduce from
hyperconductivity for functions defined
on the space and our Boolean value so
there are one functions
basically the okay you can see the
expression here it's saying like the
less than degree D part of f has weight
bounded by this
C to the quarter times F two Norm raised
to those three halves power so what does
that mean that's generally intuitive
we're just saying if your space is hyper
contractive then this Boolean value
functions all have their weights uh have
their weights really concentrated on
like uh High degrees especially those uh
Boolean functions with low density
low density coming from
this C to the one-fourth should be uh
should be much uh
really should uh cancel out the F2 Norm
to the one half on the right
okay oh okay okay maybe one thing I
should remark here is that the C really
should not depend on say the size of
this domain otherwise this kind of
implications just not like trivial
for us so we wouldn't want we wanted the
still to be like independent say of like
the size of the entire domain but could
depend on some of the parameters and
we'll mention them later
and uh another implication which is more
like implication of that Level D quality
we just saw is the small side extension
uh
or this specifically for this markup
chain that's defined by T row so okay
what do I mean by a Markov chain defined
by Tyro so
over the especially over the okay even
over the continuous space but especially
over the discrete space right T row
really depends uh really defines a
Markov chain over the uh space over your
sample space
and the
specifically the markup chain have
stationary distribution being new
and then the Boolean hypercube case uh
this t-row will be the noise operator
and this would be the noisy hypercube
that is the Markov chain that's
mentioned here so quantitatively a graph
is a a Markov chain or a graph is a
small set expander if for every small
set most of its uh edges that touches it
points towards to goes out to some some
other vertex that's outside the set
this is uh interesting more related to
like a harness of approximation
application and I believe Dora have
talked about this uh in connection with
PCB and the hardness of approximation
so I honestly don't know as much about
it so probably referring to the previous
talk could be the best way to see this
application
um
so uh okay so here I did have a short
proof of it but
I think maybe let's not care too much
about what's written here it's a just a
short proof this is just to show that
from Level the equality to small set
expansion It's relatively
straightforward if you already kind of
know the eigen space of tiro
and also there are a couple more
applications it's very interesting but I
dropped here because uh they're selling
more complicated uh I mean one of them
is from hyperconductivity quality one
can usually deduce a luxible living
quality which will help us to prove like
uh fast mixing over markup chains
an application and another application
there are also other applications to
commutorex like KKL
um theorem those type of results can
also be deduced from hyper constructive
inequality so this is kind of a result
that do have many implications
they're probably more that I'm not fully
aware of but yeah in general the the
idea is that this is a very
useful results
okay
next I want to give some examples of
hyperconductivity equality
so one of the first known maybe I this
is okay I'm not 100 sure but this is as
far as no like one of the earlier like
results in hyperconductivity qualities
in the standard gaussian space and the
result is saying like for a row between
0 and 1 over square root three we have
like T row of F's four Norm to the force
is bounded by
uh the two Norm to the force
so the seal here literally is just one
and uh also of course there's the bonami
Lemma which we've seen before and uh
actually that's literally the same like
the top expression here and the bottom
expression here is literally the same
except for we move from the standard
gaussian to zero one oh one two Boolean
hypercube and we take out the T row if I
really looking at its eigenspace and
extracted these nine to the degree of f
to the right hand side so this is our C
here
thank you
so uh
all right so uh here I want to give a
couple more examples of some lower
results in NOAA hyperconductivity
quality and I want to say that Bayern by
no means complete and I actually didn't
include some of the more recent results
um very interesting like spaces but it's
to more illustrate what kind of is known
in general
so here are a couple results and the
First Column shows this probability
space
and the second column shows what is this
constant C here
the bound and last shows like uh for
what uh type of function f this this
kind of inequality hold so previously in
examples we've been talking about it's
like this hyperconductivity and quality
generally holds for things with found
the norm but in as we see actually a
couple for a couple domains uh we know
results we know that actually it doesn't
hold general for for all functions with
bounded uh P Norm so we instead have
results that shows that they hold for a
specific class of functions called the
global functions which I will talk more
about later
um but okay let's take a look at the
domains
so
the domains uh the first one is the
uniform distribution over Boolean
hypercube and we know like nine to the
degree of s
and also the in the key wish land the
shades Mentor paper they show it for
General product space and the here the C
uh is 100 100 to the D
where Delta is a parameter of that's
related to the globalness so I won't
Define here but roughly like exponential
in D
and later we also have results about
asymmetric groups and that's also give
exponentially in polity
parameter here
and also we have
uniform distribution uh odano which is
uniform distribution over like uh case
slices so it's just a boy hypercube but
you only restrict your attention to all
the points that have k1s exactly k1s
finally is uh filmer so Donna who had
the multi-slice so instead of alphabet
size being only plus minus one you can
have like a constant sized alphabet side
okay
so some oh I need to say a disclaimer
some of these I computed myself because
as I said like they are not all like
written in the standard form so but I
hope I didn't make any mistake but if I
did please yeah let me know if if
something is wrong here
um
okay uh
these are the couple results but okay as
I said there are a couple results I
didn't include which include the very
interesting grassmanian aggressment
graphs and also like the more recent
like short code graphs that's uh by
Alice Kindler and lipsticks uh those are
all very cool results but uh they're
they belong to a slightly more
complicated domain so I'm not mentioning
them here
so one thing I want to note is that if
we take a look the first two the first
two probability space are product space
which means like uh
you know like we kind of have like n
random variables here and each of them
take value plus and minus one with equal
probability and this gives us a product
space over in random variables
and also for General product space okay
it's more clear this is actually product
space
uh these three though on the other hand
are not really product based because for
symmetric group we know that you know if
my first coordinating value
then my second coordinate can now take
value I because it's permutation group
so they're not really independent but
they're pretty close if you only look at
like uh very low degree components of
these functions because literally like
your second coordinate can be I but you
could technically be everything else so
their correlation is pretty low
similar things for like uh
uh similar things for
um the slices so for a Boolean slice we
have n random variables and we required
that essentially uh you know if they're
already K random variables so we know
takes the value one then the rest cannot
but if there are under much fewer than K
random variables taking the value y one
we technically still feel it's almost
uniform that the rest of the coordinates
still take one and negative one with uh
independent probability
um okay similar things holds for
multi-size
so the point is that they're not really
that they're not exactly product space
but they have low correlation if you
only restrict your attention to a couple
coordinates
so
some some something to say about the
techniques being used here so we know
that the bonami level uses like uh
induction basically induction and also
property of the uh like bernoullially
random variables uh
and also uh general for the general
product space uh there's this also this
technique of coupling so we have uh we
could we could do coupling uh okay sorry
out of space actually we'll later see a
proof of product space but which is not
exactly the proof that's used here
because
um here we get pretty good parameter
like exponential indeed but later we'll
see a parameter approved with worst
parameter but gives us intuition for
more General cases
um and for those spaces that's not
really product space there is a
generally used technique which is
coupling try to couple in the space with
a product space of course there will be
some loose due to the correlation but uh
uh if you're if your distribution is
close enough to product space then the
losers and not too much
and also these two results are derived
from like lots of Olivia equality so
there's for many domain there's this
almost equivalence between Lux of olive
inequality and Hyper constructivity and
I won't really talk about how do you
prove this uh it's just a
more General things
then the hyper constructivity
okay so basically the message here is
that we were able to we we've seen
results for hyperconductivity Quality
hold for General product space and also
hold it for like these almost product
spaces so the question really here is
does it hold for like can we more
generally show that for every space
that's close to product space in some
way uh that these spaces all have
um
all have hyper constructivity
so that's a question we are going to try
to answer in this talk
and uh
first through answer this question we
need to really answer the question like
what is almost product space mean
turns out that if we Define it in this
specific way then we're able to show
that for these kind of almost product
space that we call Epson product space
we are able to show hyperconductivity
and it captures some of the older
results although with worse parameters
but it also captures some new like uh
new uh new product space that was not
known before including the high
dimension expander which
which people have been talking a lot
about in this uh in this program
okay so what is a product space so
consider a product space I will write a
product space over to random variables
as this here at Omega the the sample
space is really V to the k okay
so you have just a product of set B
um and the the distribution is a is a
pro as a tensor of a marginal
distribution of one random variable
which we call MU zero
so Epsilon product space on the other
hand still have the same uh domain but
the distribution mu is not really
exactly the product but you need to
satisfy the following condition
uncoordinates a small set of coordinate
s within this k k coordinates
we had that the conditional distribution
over the rest of the over the rest of
the variables need to have to be almost
pairwise independent
so almost pairwise independentness just
saying like uh if I take two uh random
variables from this conditional
distribution
which which is obtained from
conditioning assigning the value some
arbitrary value x to the coordinates in
s
then this two random variables have
functions any functions have G defined
on them such that f and g have
correlation bounded by Epsilon
so
it's just saying there the conditional
distribution is almost pairwise
independent
so
okay
okay so as I said this uh this captures
some interesting uh instance of uh
probability space uh the one I will
mention here is the Epsilon high
dimension spender so I know that we've
covered multiple like definitions of
Epsilon high dimension expenders so I
will reiterate which one this is but
just to be more precise it's like the
Epson two side
I've seen two-sided High dimensional
expander
so how do we view a high dimensional
expander as a probability space well
actually I had a absolute high dimension
Spender
okay here I'm trying to use
non-sympicial complex language so let's
just say they're hypergraphs with
Associated Edge distribution V K to the
MU so over size K hyper edges so
consider the top level edges of these um
uh High dimensional expander to be k
hyperiges and the for example I have an
example here this is a this is a size
three hyper Edge is their top level Edge
so actually if we translate them back
into a hydrometric expander it will be
two Dimension spender but let's not
worry about that so literally this graph
is defined by having a um
having a having the top level edges
being the set of
sorry having having the having the set V
exactly being the set of vertices in
this hypergraph and the domain uh
the domain is V to the K where K here we
take to B3 in this example and this mu
is a distribution which is usually
sometimes it could vary but usually if
High dimensional expander is just a
uniform distribution over its top level
hyper edges okay so in this case it will
be just be a uniform distribution over
the set one two three and one two four
okay a small caveat here though is that
usually you know when we're defining a
probability space and we have multiple
variables the order does matter right
um but usually in high dimensional
expanders we have these Edge being set
so kind of the order doesn't matter
so what should be considered here is
that um instead of writing one two three
we can write like uh all different
orders of them and give like split the
distribution split the weight on the
hyper Edge one two three evenly to all
all of this order in different orderings
of this hyper Edge and that will give us
a order domain that's actually that's
still the same as this one
here
if we remove the order
exactly
so this is how we view uh this hyper uh
this High metric expander or a hypograph
rather as a probability space so what's
so special about the problem space
defined by the Epsilon high dimension
expander well it's the link property
that make them special
uh we know that uh for a absolute
two-sided uh high dimension expander a
spectral high dimension expander we have
that the second eigenvalue of every link
okay so let me Define what the link is
first so if we consider an any hyper
Edge in which in this case
in this case I take the edge Singleton
Edge 2 as an example so if we take two
then its link it's defined by first
taking all the hyper addresses that
contained to
and then this these sets of edges
actually uh become a new hyper graph
and we after we get this new hyper graph
we remove two from all of them so it
becomes this uh this image on the right
hand side this graph on the right hand
side and we specifically look at the
layer which has a Singleton vertices and
uh size two edges
and we look at the bipartite graph
basically defined by these two
size hyper images
and the link will always say Lambda 2 of
the link it's really like Lambda 2 the
second eigenvalue of this uh second
largest eigenvalue of this bipartite
graph
or rather sometimes you can think about
uh it as a you know if you want to think
about it just as walks on the uh
vertices you can think about instead a
graphs purely on the vertices and to to
vertices are connected internally if
they there's an edge contained most of
them
in either case uh the Lambda 2 of the
link is really the link uh number two of
the link is really the second uh
greatest eigenvalue of this um of this
bipartite graph and the lamb Epson
two-sided spectral expander ensures that
this Lambda is upper bounded by Epsilon
um so intuitively that's just saying
like uh if I take a random walk on this
bipartite graph it mixes fast uh
okay so
um
well I want to just comment to you why
these Epsilon these distributions given
by the Epsilon high dimension expanders
are actually Epsilon product space
so
let's consider what's what's the
definition of excellent product space
Epsilon product space need you to have a
simple space and the distribution
and similarly like we are able to define
a sample space and distribution and uh
expenders
the the requirement though the second
requirement is more interesting in the
Epson product space what we require is a
conditional distribution
need to uh you need to have that the
after we consider conditional
distribution any two random variables in
the conditional distribution have
boundary covariance sorry bounded
correlation
like written here and uh in absolute
high dimension expander we require that
really when we fix a when we can when we
fix a hyper Edge and consider its link
this is equivalent to you know here in
product Epson product space we fixed
assignment to a subset of coordinates
and consider it a conditional
distribution so that's the same Act
and um once we okay in high dimensional
expander once we fix
um a set of
the hyper edges and consider the link
then what we consider is this following
uh random walk
that's uh that really works from a
Vertex up to a h inside the link and
back down to the vertex so
essentially the two like uh the marginal
distribution of two random variables in
this link is really just the uniform
distribution over all the edges in the
link
therefore we're able to write the Lambda
K oh sorry we're able to write the
second eigenvalue of a link exactly in
this form
here the inner product uh
you need to make sure the inner product
is taking product uh between like
you know two connected vertices
in this link graph that we described
so essentially we can really just write
this uh requirement of Link Lambda 2 of
the link being bounded just uh
equivalently actually give us that
really the correlation between any two
coordinates in this conditional
distribution or in this link is bounded
so this is kind of a sketch of why it's
true that Epson products sorry Epson
High dimensional expander are Epsilon
product space any questions about this
um
inside X sorry s is a subset of
coordinates so a subset of random
variables X is an assignment to it
so you can select any assignment X for
us and the same so this the sound should
hold
it so uh up there we have the
requirement for all I and J right but
down there what's the correspondence for
that is it because the uh the plant
space given by a 3X is symmetric so we
don't have foreign
yeah that's right so yeah so so at some
product space is more General because uh
yeah if we restrict the in this
conditional distribution a marginal
Distribution on variable I and J could
be different and also they're uh their
joint distribution could be different
but due to the symmetric nature of how
we Define high dimension expander
remember we instead like it's naturally
an order but we just give it symmetric
ordering kind of because of that
actually all the ideas all the ijs are
the same and all the joint distributions
in between two different
different coordinates IJ are all the
same so that's right that's a good point
so we don't need to have the ID
requirement here
um
they're all allowed to substitute zeroes
so uh actually uh
what do you mean by zero you mean V
being no or no the X the links
correspond to something once but because
of the zero
sorry
um
things correspond to substituting one
you should process that because it's
zero so okay do you mean this zero or or
actually
you know she's she's embedding it's like
apartheid complex with a different
ordering and that's saying this variable
is
not just
right so actually the domain here is a v
it's not one there is yeah
this is a larger off of this
okay so yeah this is just to say that
episode extender is really a special
case of absolutely
and uh finally in this talk I will be
able to State the result
um
a result says that for all Epsilon
product space
um Omega mu and all functions f with
bounded L2 Norm if f is degree D
um
which I'll later Define what really the
greedy means
um and also uh if f is the so-called D
Delta Global functions which I'll also
later uh Define then we have that the
four Norm is bounded by this number one
this expression on the right so you see
that there's part that depends on this
Delta and this degree D and there's also
this error term that depends on Epsilon
and I should say this K really is uh
this is maybe the part I wasn't uh
explosive saying but this K is the
dimension is the level of faces that are
f is defined over
in this in this space
so okay and I want to say that was Max
mentioned already like uh the same
result is shown by bhafna Hopkins
Kaufman and labid and they're actually
able to obtain a better uh expression
here
I think they're able to get exponential
in D
um
and their uh their results specialize
for Epsilon High dimensional expander
and the techniques are different so yeah
so in this in the rest of this talk I
will talk a little bit about the
technique in in this paper
um
okay
oh dependence on K
I think exponentially okay
I don't exactly remember but I think
it's exponential okay
so so okay so it means like really you
want your Epsilon to be inverse
exponentially smaller than k for this
bound to really work so you really need
really really good uh high dimension
expanders
spectral high dimension extenders
okay so uh before talking about the
proof framework then I feel I should
really explain why do we have this
Global function restriction
so recall that actually when we were
talking about some implications of high
dimension sorry of hyperconductivity we
mentioned one of them is a Level D
quality
so the Level D and quality uh
and general says something like oh if
you have like a hyperconductivity for
all functions as then you should have
that uh those Boolean valued function
with low weights so here weights means
low expectations
with low weights should have their um
have their weights concentrated on high
degrees so the high degree part of the
function should have large Norm
um however this is really not the case
uh in uh in like uh at some product
space and not also not the case in
things like uh very biased hypercube or
slice with uh or very biased slices uh
and there is and the reason is that okay
if we consider like uh in a very uh in
the Epsilon product space maybe my
function can be only of degree one my
function can just be the indicator uh
function okay it's not exactly yeah but
my function could be an indicator
function of uh of whether my first
coordinate is equal to one
if I have bad then this is a really low
weight function this could be a really
low wave function if your alphabet size
is really large right this is could like
in our case it's like order of one over
n because our alphabet is from one
through n it's all the vertices
however uh the this have this function
literally I have no weight on the high
degree part because this is just
indicator function that depends only on
the first coordinate so it couldn't
possibly be at high degree uh therefore
this lovely inequality doesn't really
hold and that tells us basically this uh
General hyper constructivity couldn't
hold especially couldn't hold for the
function type of function I just talked
about which is like indicator function
of a small set of coordinates taking a
certain value
so because of that we need to exclude
these kind of functions that we couldn't
hope to get hyperconductivity for
uh but it turns out that actually
excluding these type of function is
enough I think that's a more interesting
result like all functions that's far
from these kind of functions are are
going to have hypercontractivity
inequality
okay so specifically uh a function we
call a function f is D Delta Global if
for any set of coordinates that's of
size and most D and any assignment X
over these set of random variables we
have that if we restrict our domain to
just these um
to suggested these uh space this
Subspace where the coordinates in s are
assigned to X and we take the L2 Norm of
this new restrictive function it's upper
bounded by Delta
or square root Delta so there's a square
so it is saying like uh you couldn't
have a subpart that's too you know
that's too Salient uh for example if
actually our function is the indicator
function then when I assign that the
first coordinate for example to be one
then this will be like one so that
wouldn't be bounded
um
but so that's not a global function the
example we just mentioned
okay so these exclude this requirement
really exclude all the functions that
are that are
close to being a dictator function as a
solution
so to talk about the final way to talk
about actually the proof we need to have
a couple of useful like Notions to
discuss so literally there are two
things you really need the first type of
thing you need for this kind of pervisa
or sagno or
and orthogonal decomposition for the
function f uh in the space
so here is an example for the
decomposition in the Boolean hypercube
case in the Boolean hypercube we have
this decomposition being like the
Fourier characters
and the coefficient here are just the
Fourier coefficient
and we know that these are our
orthogonal decomposition and therefore
they're unique console
and another thing we really need is a
like a derivative operator for these
functions
so we can Define these function these
like a d sub s of x to be derivative
respect with respect to like variables
in the set s and evaluated at the point
x
so X is assignment to any arbitrary
assignment of s
and we really need so that this
derivative operator decreased the degree
of the function
from degree of f to a most degree of f
minus size of s
so
foreign
so mostly what I will do is I will show
the proof actually first for the product
space because
um our proof for the Epson product space
really mostly follows the proof of the
product space but with some relaxation
because we couldn't possible couldn't
really get a nice orthogonal basis that
are based the degree decomposition so I
will introduce what are the two Notions
we mentioned before what are they in
product space so in product space there
is um this General decomposition called
efforts time decomposition that actually
is orthogonal and unique
so
so we can decompose F into a subset of
like f equal to S whereas our subsets of
K
and uh such that when smt are not equal
then F equal to S and F equal to T they
really have zero inner product under
this distribution
and the
okay they're defined really by this
projection
they're defined by this projection
operator a sub s a sub s is literally a
projection operator projecting F on all
the coordinates uh
on onto only those coordinates in s so
it's taking it's it's taking expectation
over all the rest of the coordinates
that's the projection
probably only thing that need to be
remembered is that these are like
orthogonal and unique decomposition over
product spaces
and then we can
um equivalently Define like the
derivative it's really analogous to the
derivative we see in calculus it's
literally summation over all T that
contains s uh F equal to S also
derivative operator because we take the
derivative and evaluate it at X it's a
function really on the rest of the
coordinates That's not including those
in this
so because of that we have its degree as
a most DF minus s
okay and I want to say like really the
degree of a component is really
uh
you can a degree on function you just
look at the largest and non-zero
component in this summation so for
example F equal to S this part would
have degree size of s
and uh the component that have the
largest uh the largest non-zero
component would give you the degree
so now we with this two uh with this two
notion we're able to talk about how to
show hyper constructivity over the
product space so specifically in this
talk we'll quickly I think yeah we'll
quickly go over this how to prove this
in general uh as you can see here is a
400d to the power of D so it's D to the
D
a coefficient in this hyper
constructivity inequality so it's not
optimal
um yeah and the uh
yeah I'll talk I'll maybe address this a
little bit more later
and the this is really done also by
induction uh we just like bonami Lemma
but however bonami we do induction by
the number of coordinates here we do
induction by the degree of the function
s so if we're able to decompose uh this
four Norm into some component involved
two norm and some other components still
having four Norm however it's on the
four Norm on the derivative of f which
we know just by the discussion
previously have lower degree than the
function f
okay so this is a decomposition some
part involved two norms and some part
involves a four Norm of a lower degree
function
yeah I'm thinking okay okay maybe I
should still cover parts of it but I
think I will probably skip some of the
things that's a little bit too much to
cover here given the time uh we we can
still follow this this line though so
this line is really rewriting the four
Norm
um as like a two Norm of the function f
squared
okay so this is like nothing this is
like this just by definition
and next what one can do is really to uh
write the
recall that we're still on product space
so we have all the nice things about
unique decomposition we're still going
to decomposition okay so because of that
we can write this L2 Norm uh into the
summation of a bunch of L2 Norm squared
okay because they're also going to
decomposition
and finally we can open up the f-square
inside by also writing as each of the f
as summation over F equal to T so we
have this large term inside here
so we opened up twice
okay now at this point we're we're going
to address each of these kind of
components
so we divide
this term into we treat them separately
and divide in them into three cases
First cases okay let's see we have this
diagram here first case is when they
actually have non-zero intersection all
three of them so something here in the
middle
um second case is when like when some
some like some element it's either in
this part this part or this part
so there are only some element that's
only in one of the three
okay
if none of the first two cases happen
actually one can convince oneself that
it must be then that T1 symmetric
difference T2 is equal to S because
everything needs to be in in one of
these three small petals
okay
now we'll just quickly say that uh this
first in the first component when there
is something in the middle of the three
then what one can do is really like
because there are some some coordinates
they share what one can do is one can
condition on that coordinate once one
condition on that coordinates this
component become a one degree at least
one degree less function
so uh we kind of what kind of what
happened this this become a L2 Norm of
some new function that have degree lower
than our original f
so this case this case really become
this component here
I won't comment too much on that uh I
would just say like uh this is more
mechanical so
just uh
to kind of believe it at this point
maybe
the more interesting parts are the
second
and the third case so it turns out that
second case in the second case this type
of term here in the summation completely
vanished they're just zero and the
reason being
um
when there is some eye uniquely in just
one of these three components there are
two kind of cases either I is in s or i
is in either T1 or T2
when I is in s
what happens is that this component
become can be written as uh okay a is
equal to F1 oh sorry F equal to T1 F
equal to T2 literally this component
only depend on coordinates in T1 Union
T2 and because this is product space so
we can actually write this equality that
it's equal to
81 Union T2 so we project F this product
onto just the coordinates T1 T2 and then
and then take its equal to S component
because because the I is an S but not in
T1 nor T2 so s is not a subset of T1 and
T2
and because of that actually this
component
this inside this inside function
has zero component on the subset s
because because s really is not
contained inside
these set of coordinates and therefore
this is actually zero
decomposition
foreign
we can we can double count some cases
yeah the first two cases are not
mutually exclusive the last one is is
just capturing the things that's neither
one or two that's right
um similarly when I is in either T1 and
T2 in which case we actually just assume
they're in T1
what we can do is we can we can the
inside FT1 ft2 we can write it as uh we
project f f equal to T1 onto the space
of all coordinates except for I
uh or the reason being that because
later we're going to take the projection
onto equal to S so
the part depending on I will vanish
anyways so because of uh actually
because of or so I'm going to
decomposition we're able to we're able
to do this
um
right
and then we
because of that we have that uh
a uh
this this whole component is really
depending uh
here okay so
sorry I'm confusing myself a little bit
um
uh all right uh okay you're saying that
it's because if we okay this is
self-adjoined a self-addrained operator
so you're saying we're moving it to
applying this a projection to this F
equal to T2
foreign
will still give you f equal to T2 I
think
it's zero sorry let me
this a operator
kills everything that contains
coordinates outside of T1
[Music]
okay and as in that case actually it
does contain the code left outside of T1
Union D2
I see and so the function inside has
nothing on the S component
s
um okay I see uh I thought though
um I thought though the actual thing
happening here is that because T1 is now
containing te excluded I so what happens
is that this part this first part here
will become a zero
okay uh
yeah sorry that confuses myself uh sorry
so so yeah this is the actual thing what
what happens is that this first
component when a a k it's good I is
applied to F equal to T1 it's going to
give a zero function and uh because of
that this whole thing will evaluate
oh okay so let me just quickly say the
last one uh the last one uh
but uh but the last one is saying like
Okay if we have I think we'll do T1
let's say for the t2 equal to S such
that the Symmetry difference are of T1
T2 is equal to S then we can write the
first in equality
um that is because uh
uh okay as projecting on the space
actually should have included many more
things than just equal to S part it
should also include all the equal to S
Prime whereas Prime are strictly subsets
of s uh however that actually reduced to
our case two uh because then that
implies like there is some component in
T1 or T2 that's not in s so those turns
actually would vanish because of that we
can write it this equality
and uh and also because like two uh
yeah and the and later we can also write
this because this is a product
distribution
as a result we know that this is the
product this to uh these two functions
and the first function is really a
function only over coordinates in s
intersect T1 and the second function is
really a function over the coordinates s
intersect T2
so and also this is a product
distribution so they're completely
disjoint and the independent functions
as a result and one can write this L2
Norm is just a L2 Norm of each of them
in product together times together uh
multiplied together sorry and uh
therefore it's finally bounded by this
L2 Norm of each of them multiplied
together
and this part is actually going to be
the part that contributes to this first
term which have uh
there is additionally a step I'm going
to skip about once you're here you you
can actually apply the standard hyper
constructivity over the Boolean
hypercube
um to get the sink here because we see
that 9 to the D here actually exactly
come from that
[Music]
um
all right so this is roughly how this
proof of this K Lemma goes and once you
have this you really have the original
product distribution uh
uh hyper constructivity and okay I
really should have covered this earlier
but uh you know like once we want to
move away and move to the Epson product
space the only thing that happens is
like we still Define the projection
operator as before we still kind of
Define the F equal to S component as
before except for because it's not a
product space we end up not having them
being orthogonal they're just Epsilon
close to orthogonal so we don't have
unique decomposition many discussion
we've seen just before about case two
and three only hold approximately so
when before we can write equality or
before we can write equal to zero now we
can really only write uh
it was a error term of O of K Epsilon F2
in the with really with the change of
that we're able to
get a get through the entire proof with
a error term here
is really three so I will just talk
about two open directions I think might
be interesting
[Music]
um
so one interesting one thing is we've
seen that in this proof although I
didn't really get into it but very
crucially we rely on the fact that the
link expansion okay and specifically in
the case that we have absolute high
dimension expander really require that
domain have like Epsilon uh bounded like
Lambda 2 links
so that's really fit the definition of
epson High dimensional expander however
for other type of high dimensional
expander that also are probably more
appropriate for applications like
testing or like hardness reduction uh
for example all those like coastalic
spender or robust testability uh robust
tester or like co-boundary expenders
how are this kind of uh
property going to be shown on over such
domains is another it's a question I
think it's interesting
and also like as I said there are
already results on like Grassman grabs
and also like short code graphs which
are literally non-communitive like
spaces so how to in general show things
on those spaces is also interesting uh
Direction and finally uh I want to say
like uh we see that in the induction
it's there's this loss of like 400d to
the D which is not really optimal
and then another interesting thing is
like really we didn't make use of the
noise operator at all like really for
like things like the continuous space
the proof of hyperconductivity really
heavily relies on using those like noise
operators but here in the proof we never
seen it even occurring so possibly could
there be a like a ways to incorporate
like stochastic process and all those
noise operators in the proof so that we
can save that 400d to the D factor in
the front
that will be the things I think are
probably interesting to some of you guys
okay so yeah that's it if you
[Applause]
so we're a bit over time but if there
are any quick questions now is the time
foreign
[Music]
okay I see uh
so in the case that it depends on and
it's usually when this marginal
Distribution on one coordinate they're
really biased
so that's why it shows up uh like you
said on over K there over the slices
and when they're depending on in general
they should depend on degree actually
because our noise operator T row uh
follows the degree decomposition
so uh yeah in general it should depend
on the if it's written in the form like
a four Norm of f valid by two normal
that's without that hero inside
I was just wondering is it well
understood where the global requirement
is necessary
I think we kind of rendered at least we
know how to predict it because we know
specific functions are custom to be bad
which are those like uh uh like uh
indicator of sub cubes or like those are
the literally I think those are the bad
cases so we kind of do know what
explains that we're going to get
oh like sorry we couldn't get General
again
[Applause]
so we'll come back at 3 30.